trans influencer Dylan Mulvaney speaking publicly
about the backlash that ensued after she featured
Bud Light beers and two Instagram posts back in
April Mulvaney says the company never reached out
to her after the onslaught of threats bullying
and hate speech I was waiting for the brand to
reach out to me but they never did for months now
I've been scared to leave my house I have been
ridiculed in public I've been followed and I have
felt a loneliness that I wouldn't wish on anyone
for a company to hire a trans person and then not
publicly stand by them is worse in my opinion than
not hiring a trans person at all in a statement
to the New York Times a spokesperson for Bud
Light said quote as we've said we remain committed
to programs and Partnerships we have forged over
decades with organizations across a number of
communities including those in the lgbtq plus
Community the privacy and safety of our employees
and our partners is always our top priority